the Romans used the first-person pronoun
eagle which survives in the modern
Romance languages with the colorful
range of pronunciations yo
Dale Ile ei to address you languages
continue using the second person pronoun
to which is less varied to to do it deep
to things get more interesting when I
refer to someone besides you and me
nominative forms of that word aloo you
learned as a definite article drop in
for another visit
Alette for he Allah for she
actually Allah refers to masculine nouns
in general not only humans and Allah to
feminine nouns so for example lacasa the
house is also an 11 pronoun similar to
it or this point to generic neuter items
like ox significa sassy she a shall
significant just significant but usually
languages express this as significant on
its own return to the second person and
inject a bit of culture a bit of
politeness to be precise modern Romance
languages make a politeness distinction
at least a binary one between familiar
and polite who is a familiar or informal
pronoun polite pronounced very in Spain
Portugal and Italy languages innovated
third-person pronouns to speak to you
politely including Italian lei Spanish
who stays and Portuguese will say other
languages including Romanian romance and
French use second person plural pronouns
to refer to you politely
where we have.we bulghur Latin speakers
had nose nosh Moo loose noise
los altos literally we others also shows
up in western languages including
Spanish and oxygen nosotros whose ultras
boozled Romance languages have a
separate pronoun for the second person
plural all of you voz food booze boy as
with nosotros vosotros you others makes
an appearance in some languages vosotros
pues Altos languages that innovate
polite third-person pronouns in the
singular have the same polite plurals
Lauro ustedes massage Portuguese and
Latin American speakers use otherwise
formal pronouns who steady simple search
to refer to all of you well vosotros and
wash are archaic in French and Romansh
most doubles as a singular polite
pronoun vishanti means all of you sing
as expected but also you sir Madame sing
the plurals of L and L are used for they
as with nouns nominative plurals ending
in a vowel are found in eastern romance
accusative plurals with a final s in the
West elite Romanian gay
or elos Spanish adios French eel
feminine Allah and Allah refer to a
group of women or feminine plural Val's
Italian just uses the genitive form
Lauro for both genders instead
something's creeping back to the surface
again and it's that quirk we learned
about romance verbs pronoun dropping in
classical Latin vulgar latin and most
Romance languages verbs normally get
used on their own without these subject
pronouns you've just learned canto on
its own means I sing canthus on its own
means you sing
this is emphatically not true of French
romance or a few of their regional
neighbors where the once optional ago
gonto gives the required result yell
chant this is where subject pronouns and
verbs interconnect they match or agree
in person and number the subject a go
goes with cantle no swiff cantamos and
so on for a sense of this integration
take a look at the verb I've been using
over and again compadre in the present
indicative with its subject pronouns
these are the basic personal subject
pronouns will build upon as we dig into
object pronouns until then keep your
Latin vulgar